economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando
américa latina chile reveló un estudio
sobre las consecuencias que ha tenido la
pandemia en el bolsillo de los
ciudadanos de los chilenos cuéntanos
hola santiago mire se hizo una encuesta
entre más de tres mil viviendas
particulares para saber qué efectos
socioeconómicos se han desprendido de la
pandemia uno de los hallazgos fue que se
duplicó la tasa de hogares que creen que
su ingreso no les alcanza en 2019 al 16
5% de ellos no le era suficiente su
ingreso para financiar los gastos pero
en julio de 2020 en plena crisis ya esa
tasa afectaba a 1 de cada dos hogares y
ahora es del 31% otra de las
conclusiones es que la mitad de los
hogares de clase media exhibió mayores
niveles de pobreza hay santiago una
escala que va del 20 por ciento más
pobre de la población hasta los más
ricos y se mide en lo que se llaman
quintiles que van del 1 al 5
respectivamente siendo uno el de los más
bajos recursos pues casi un 60 por
ciento de los hogares de clase media
calle
dentro de esa escala hablemos ahora de
eeuu de la administración del presidente
joe biden quiere reversar algunas de las
decisiones del ex presidente de trump
como por ejemplo las decisiones que tomó
en torno a tick tock santiago usted se
acuerda que el ex presidente de donald
trump intentó por todos los medios
obligar a que las casas matrices de esta
aplicación y también de widget vendieran
sus operaciones en eeuu
pues él consideraba que era presentaban
un grave peligro para la seguridad
nacional que el tema se enredó
finalmente en los tribunales y volvió a
aparecer hoy el nuevo presidente joe
biden a través de su departamento de
justicia envió solicitudes a los
tribunales para que frenen todos los
procesos que estuvieran pendientes para
hacer un análisis más a profundidad
antes de tomar cualquier decisión y no
estamos hablando de cualquier empresa
santiago widget tiene 19 millones de
usuarios activos en la unión americana y
la red
vídeos cortos tienen más de 100 millones
nada despreciable hablemos ahora de
argentina el gobierno de este país está
buscando acuerdos de precios y también
de salarios por la alta inflación que
presenta este país más problemas en la
argentina sí ya sabemos que este es uno
de los países más inflacionarios de la
región y le voy a dar un ejemplo
mientras que en colombia bolivia perú
los precios de la canasta familiar en
2019 en 2020 subieron menos del 2 por
ciento en argentina lo hicieron en 36% y
el inicio de 2021 no mostró mejoría
alguna con una elevada inflación del 4%
solamente en enero presionada por el
aumento en las tarifas de televisión e
internet pues ante este escenario el
gobierno de alberto fernández si toda
esta semana a los sindicatos y
trabajadores de gremios empresarios
también porque quiere buscar acuerdos y
precios y sobre los pesos y sobre los
salarios también más que una camisa de
fuerza lo que se busca es que haya
consensos para que los precios no se
disparen y que al mismo tiempo los
empleados tengan un mejor poder
adquisitivo y pasamos a la comisión
europea que empeoró sus proyecciones
para este año otra vez
pues previamente este organismo creía
que el crecimiento para el bloque de 27
países iba a ser del 4 1 por ciento pero
ahora paso al 37 sin embargo la comisión
interpretan las cifras como una salida a
una crisis sin precedentes de 2020
porque al menos habrá crecimiento además
se prevé un 22 2022 con mejores
perspectivas más temprano de esther
herrera se desde bruselas a los puntos
más
bruselas cree que se empieza a ver la
luz al final del túnel en la economía
después de una pandemia que ha afectado
gravemente a los países europeos y se
espera que con el refuerzo de las
campañas de vacunación en las próximas
semanas y también sobre todos los fondos
de recuperación que se espera que puedan
llegar a finales del verano pueda
mejorar la economía sustancialmente por
lo que hay motivos para la esperanza en
la economía de la unión europea varios
indicadores otro récord en la bolsa de
nueva york esta vez fueron los índices
standard and poor's y nasdaq en una
semana muy movida de resultados
empresariales en europa del informe de
este jueves de la comisión europea vivo
el optimismo y casi todas las bolsas se
cerraron en positivo y en américa latina
hubo resultados dispares con pérdidas
más altas para la bolsa mexicana cifra
del día para el cierre los más de 3.000
millones de dólares en utilidades que
tuvo en 2020 astrazéneca la
biofarmacéutica británico sueca que
junto con oxford es una de las
desarrolladoras de las vacunas para kobe
estuvieron 150 159 por ciento es decir
más que se duplicaron frente a 2019
daniela muchas gracias por este reporte
del mundo económico es todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nuestra programación en más para ver
buenas noches